so many people like oh how do you look
like that or what do you do and
you know i work at it and it's hard and
i have
you know a crazy background with
modeling and you know just you know body
dysmorphia and like all of that that you
know a lot of people don't know
because you know i'm not really going to
open that up but i decided to with these
conversations because
i do think it's the perfect platform for
it it's the perfect platform and
you know things don't come easy you know
i do have to work for it i hate when
i'll
ask someone like oh what did you do and
like oh i had hamburgers and french
fries and
you know i'm like no you didn't you know
what i mean like
you eat like lettuce you make the
lettuce and tomatoes with the lettuce in
the tomato
but um no but i definitely and i love
you know i love doing with her you know
and
it's been fun we also got to um talk to
a girl named it's me tanks
wait what do you know team no oh my god
you guys have to follow her her name is
christina her name is it's me tanks and
she talks boys
botox and rich mom culture and you just
have to like she pokes fun at it oh
yeah okay okay it is phenomenal
phenomenal well everybody molly's
podcast is called lipstick on the rim
you've got to check it out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever